snakes on your left snakes on your right
giant cockroaches behind you and in
front of you the open sea
it's difficult to get to this island in
the first place but it's almost
impossible to get out alive
here's how to survive snake island
about 33 kilometers off the coast of
brazil near the state of sao paulo
there's a place so dangerous that it's
uninhabited and closed to visitors or
tours de gamada grande also known as
snake island is only 430 000 square
meters but it is home to a lot of danger
it's estimated that there is at least
one snake per square meter and about
four 000 of them are golden lancehead
pit vipers they're one of the deadliest
snakes in the world
this place is feared even by local
residents who tell stories of people
going to the island but never coming
back
how deadly is a golden lancehead's venom
what other creatures are on the island
and why could pirates be a problem too
unless you're in charge of fixing this
lonely lighthouse there's no reason for
you to go to snake island but if you
arrive there by accident
how could you survive
step one
sail carefully
if you go sailing or fishing near the
island you'd better keep your distance
snake island is surrounded by rocks so
it is dangerous to swim near it and it
could break your boat in late february
of 2019 a small fishing boat with six
men got caught in a storm it began
sinking near snake island knowing
exactly which island they were near four
of the men decided to swim to shore the
other two remained in the boat choosing
to die on their own terms
the four men were on the island for
three days they stayed on the beach
without entering the forest
for three days they drank rain water and
eight bananas they found on the edge of
the forest then they spotted a boat
going near the island and quickly swam
to it
the boat picked them up and delivered
them to the nearest emergency room on
the coast
step 2
watch out for cockroaches
lethal vipers are not the only threat on
snake island there are many non-venomous
snakes giant cockroaches and locusts
that cover the island if you're anywhere
on snake island you should regularly
check for these not so little critters
and try to avoid them the best you can
on the other hand if you have a strong
stomach they could save you from
starving cockroaches are safe to eat and
a good source of protein and essential
amino acids bon appetit
step 3
deal with the snakes
if you're stuck on this island you will
have to face the snakes
try to find a stick it will help you
fight the snakes off and prevent them
from biting you if you get bitten
prepare to suffer since the golden
lancehead pit vipers on the island
evolved naturally they developed a venom
up to five times stronger than a regular
landsat vipers
this powerful venom causes severe
physical complications including kidney
failure brain hemorrhaging and
intestinal bleeding
it can also cause muscle tissue to die
so you're going to feel as if your skin
is melting
take off any rings watches and bracelets
as they could become really hard to
remove if an arm begins swelling
if you have an epipen use it to treat
symptoms of anaphylaxis like swelling of
the face mouth or throat hives or
difficulty breathing
the only way to increase your chance of
surviving is with medical help which
takes us to our next step
step four bring a doctor
only biologists and researchers visit
the island
they study the golden lancehead pit
vipers and the brazilian navy visits
once a year to maintain the lighthouse
which has been automated since the 1920s
the government requires that every team
that visits the island includes a doctor
if a golden lance head bites you you
have a seven percent chance of dying
being treated by a doctor can reduce
those chances to 3 percent
step 5
beware of pirates
despite the island's dangerous snakes
wildlife smugglers also known as
biopirates have made frequent stops to
trap and sell the snakes
a single golden lance head pit viper is
worth about ten thousand to thirty
thousand dollars on illegal markets and
since this is the only place where they
exist the golden lance heads are listed
as endangered on the international union
for conservation of nature's red list
you escaped snake island alive
but it's not the only dangerous place
around south america
you could end up in the amazon
surrounded by these blood sucking fish
and if you're not careful they might try
to swim up your urethra oh want to know
how to stop them
find out here
on how to survive